when people ask you what happened here
tell them the North remembers tell them
winter came for house free what's up
ladies and gentlemen welcome back from
my Game of Thrones Season eight episode
to plot leek breakdown video I just
uploaded my breakdown for episode 1 and
that one wasn't too bad most of the
scenes did line up with the direction
the show seems to be going in based off
of house season 7 ended today I am going
to go through the scenes in episode 2
and see what does or does not make sense
like I said in the first video most of
what I will say will be based on my
opinions and speculation there hasn't
been a ton of spoilers this offseason so
I can only confirm or deny so much some
photos videos and reports have came out
that do give us a good idea of how
certain things will play out next season
but there still isn't enough available
information for me to know how many
scenes in this leak are real or not but
I will use what I have so without
further ado let's get started season 8
episode 2 began with Davos and Gunn jury
showing up at Winterfell what the
remaining dragonglass
as they were unloading the dragonglass
Arya and Brienne were training in the
yard and this is when Aria and ginjury
reunite this leads to a conversation
about Melisandre and Aria and Davos both
say they will kill her when they see her
again I haven't seen enough evidence to
know if this scene will take place I
know ginjury is returning for season 8
because a fan took a photo of Gendry was
several other cast members in Northern
Ireland I believe he was with four or
five other characters so we will
definitely see Gendry again Gendry was
not at the dragon pit scene nor was he
on Dragonstone when Jon and Daenerys
decided they would travel by boat
together
so there is no way to confirm where ken
jury will be seen next when everyone met
back on Dragonstone and decided they
would sail to white Harbor Davos was in
that scene with Jon there wasn't any
mention of dragonglass in that scene so
I
no reason to believe Davis and ginjury
will stay behind to bring the rest of
the dragon class to Winterfell together
in my opinion Davis left Dragonstone
with them since he was there during that
meeting plus he is John's right hand so
he will need to be close by based off al
season 7 ended in the few set photos I
have seen I would have to say this scene
is incorrect Davos and Geng jury will
not show up together an episode two I
think Davos will be with John and
Daenerys the whole time when John and
Daenerys made their plans about how they
would get to Winterfell John never gave
Davos any other instructions so he must
be with them still there is a
possibility that this does happen but I
don't think it's very likely Arya and
ginjury will reunite but not like this
the next scene was in volantis when
Melisandre in Canberra talking to a
large group of followers over lore in
this scene they talked about the night
king coming and how they all needed to
go to Westeros to help I think there is
a very good chance we could see
something like this I'm not sure what
episode it would be in but we know
Melisandre left for volantis and she
said she would be returning
Melisandre would have no reason to go to
volantis and come right back unless she
was going there for something that could
assist her in the Great War we all know
there are theories about MELAS ons are
getting the fiery hand and we know
kinvaras supports Dany
so we might see her again also
Melisandre was spotted in Belfast during
filming in a new photo just came out and
some people are saying Melisandre was in
the photo dressed in red and she was
surrounded by soldiers of the north as
of right now there is no evidence of kin
Vora making a return to the show but
that doesn't mean she won't I always
felt like there was a very good chance
she would come back the waken Vora and
Melisandre are keep speaking to Varys
seems like we should get some closure
with them I think it's safe to say
Melisandre is coming back but can vara
cannot be confirmed and would it make
much sense for Melisandre to travel that
far just to come back empty-handed she's
going to volantis for a very good reason
and it might have something to do with
this scene I won't rule this out just
yet
I would love for Melisandre in cavora to
show up what the small force of their
own the next scene was at Castle black
and it showed
the aftermath of the attack there beric
Dondarrion was still alive but Lord
Commander Ed was not it said Castle
black was in ruins and barracks said he
must go south to play his final part in
the war like I said in the episode one
breakdown video I don't think this makes
a whole lot of sense
I believe barrack and tormund are alive
in fact torment was already seen in
Belfast preparing to film so I know he's
alive and beric and torment might have
to go to Castle black in order to get
down off the wall since the night King
destroyed East to watch by the sea
barrack and torment might be stuck at
the top of the wall until they find a
castle that has something for them to
use to get down
since Castle black is the closest castle
that is operational they may have to go
that far but I doubt the night King
sends his army their next Castle black
is a very small target and it's
completely out of his way he seems to be
moving south and Castle black is about
150 miles away from east watch I think
it would be ridiculous for the night
king to send men there just to kill
about 30 crows I have no way to prove
this scene is fake but common sense
tells me it's not right I guess the
night King could always spare a few
hundred White's just to clean out the
Nights Watch but I don't think it's very
likely I think he's heading south to
take on much bigger targets the night
King will probably wipe out everything
in his way but as of right now Castle
black is nowhere near him so I can't buy
this scene until I see further proof of
it happening this next scene is back in
the gods way what brain stark at the
weirwood tree this is when brain sees
his first set of visions his visions
consist of images of wild fire blue
dragon fire a bed of blood
Melisandre looking into the flames a
black silhouette the night King Jaime
Lannister during his first trip to
Winterfell and bran falling from the
tower now obviously there is no way for
me to confirm or deny any of these
visions I am very confident Bryan will
have more visions next season but there
is no way for me to know what he will
see I will talk about this some more
once we get to the scenes when some of
these things start to play out in the
later episodes when brain comes out of
these visions he is surrounded by
several main characters and this is the
first time he tells jaw and he needs to
talk and
tell him the truth but they immediately
go into the main hall John tells
everyone about the recent attacks in the
north and how they need to fashion all
the dragonglass into weapons I think
this sounds plausible enough I do think
the night king will strike a few
northern castles before he gets to
Winterfell
so I'm sure they will get word that the
night king is destroying everything in
his path on his way to them plus it
makes sense for John to tell everyone to
turn the dragonglass into weapons for
everyone to use John already said
something like this in season seven and
there was a report about all the
unsullied using dragon glass spears
during filming this is also the same
scene when Sam Tarly stands up and tells
John he has his father's Valyrian steel
sword heart Spain it might not go down
like this but same still has that sword
for a reason they showed him leaving the
Citadel with it so it needs to be used
at some point there would be no reason
for Sam to take it unless it gets used
plus we all know how important Valyrian
steel is it's much more durable than
dragon glass and some of the best
swordsmen will be in Winterfell so I
would be willing to bet on Sam doing
something with arts Bayman I actually
made a video about this sword and you
could check that out and see who I think
will end up wilting it during the Great
War after the scene in the main hall
ends Daenerys tells John she would like
to speak with him in private this is
when Danny tells John she is pregnant
all of you should already know how I
feel about this I'm 100% confident
Daenerys is pregnant they foreshadowed
this happening nearly a dozen times in
season 7 I also made a video about this
too and I compiled all the evidence that
I think points to Daenerys being
pregnant
I think Daenerys telling this to John is
very plausible and likely to happen at
some point next season I don't know
which episode but it will be in one of
the early ones obviously I have never
been pregnant but it probably doesn't
take too long for a woman to notice
something is growing inside of her her
especially Daenerys considering she has
went through several months of a
pregnancy before back in season 1 the
next scene as Jaime and Bronn showing up
at the twins in order to find as many
men as possible to take north with them
when they get to the castle they are
greeted by several women that are
rolling the twins since Oriya killed
most of the men I believe there is a
very good chance of this happening as
well we know Jamie is heading north and
there is evidence of the phrase
returning next season
a casting call went out a few months ago
and they were looking for two young
ladies
then another report came out saying
those two ladies will play twins at the
twins it will be Serra and sarra frame
Jamie obviously has a relationship and
alliance with the Freys so it makes
sense he would stop there at some time
next season and since they did cast two
girls to play as phrase it kind of makes
sense that this could be why I don't
think Jamie will show up with a large
force but I wouldn't doubt if he tried
Jaime and Bronn stopping at the twins
seems pretty reasonable to me the next
scene was in King's Landing and it's
what Cersei and Khyber and checking up
on the city's defenses they were having
wildfire placed at each gate that enters
the city and Qyburn had more ballistas
made to take down the Dragons this seems
fairly reasonable - we know Qyburn had
one ballista made so I don't think it's
too crazy to think he would have more
made I know I would if I were them and I
would also have any and all of the
Wildfire located so it could be on
standby in case of an attack
we know Cersei has no problem using it
in our own city and there is photo
evidence of an attack taking place in
King's Landing no one knows how much
wildfire may be left but I always had a
feeling there was plenty more left over
Khyber might not have a dozen more
ballistas made but it would be wise to
make more than one considering there are
more than one dragons in the enemy's
army I do think a scene similar to this
will happen then we get a scene with
Filan and his small team of Ironborn men
looking for Yara it says they go to the
Iron Islands looking for her but she's
not there we already know this is what
Theon's gonna be doing next season his
last scene was on the beach at
Dragonstone when he got in a fight then
said they're going to rescue Yara we
will see Theon attempt to get her back
one way or another some spoilers did
come out over a month ago and they said
Theon and Yara were filming together in
a studio there wasn't any photos but
someone saw them together they didn't
see Yaron at the time but it doesn't
mean he won't be involved in de scenes
if those reports are
Fionan Yura will share some screen time
again one of them could die in the scene
but they are going to meet at least one
more time as of right now there is no
proof that Theon goes to the Iron
Islands to find her but there are only
so many places she can be so I won't
rule this out just yet
Theon could go there first this scene
makes some sense for the most part they
scene is followed up by urine and Yara
on the silence Yara is in the main cabin
and she's been beaten and her tongue was
cut out by your own I cannot confirm or
deny any of this obviously there is no
proof that Yara loses her tongue but I
will say urine is known for doing this
in the books every man that Cruz his
ship has no tongue we even saw Euron's
men cutting out tongues in season seven
when they attacked Yara and Theon's
fleet I personally hope your on doesn't
cut out her tongue but he does have a
history of doing this the longer Yara is
what you're on the more danger she is in
of something like this happening now
this next scene sounds exactly like one
of my prediction videos it says bran Sam
tearing and the maester are looking
through the books from the Citadel
trying to find answers about how to
defeat the night king we already know
Sam told brain where to look to see
Rhaegar Liana's marriage and it seems
likely that they will continue to work
together but now we have Tyrion coming
to Winterfell as well and we all know
he's book savvy - the reason why Sam
took those books and left the Citadel
was mostly because they weren't taking
him serious at the Citadel and Sam knows
how urgent this situation is he took
everything that relates to the long
night and the others hoping to find
answers and they wouldn't have shown sam
taking those books unless he was going
to find more answers and them later
since he has brand to go back in time
and confirm things I'm sure he will
continue to work with him the actor who
plays Sam is named John Bradley and
during a recent interview he said Sam
and bran will be having more scenes
together next season and I would like to
think we will see a scene just like this
Sam will use his books and brain will
use his Wi-Fi connection to fact-check
those books and find a solution Tyrion
may or may not be involved but
everything else ounds very plausible the
last scene is with the night King and
Vasari on destroying the car hole
and now whatever this in the first video
but I will say it again
I really love the idea of ending the
first two episodes with attacks from the
night king this would be a great way to
end each episode with big cliffhangers
and it would also build more and more
fear with each passing episode knowing
the night king is getting closer and his
army is getting bigger there is also
some evidence that suggests something
like this may happen little Ned umber
and Elise Karstark were seen in belfast
filming scenes and they are now in
control of their families castles Ned
will be at the last hearth and Elise
will be at the karhold if they brought
these two actors back it could be
because they get killed next season
because they are pretty much in the
night Kings path if the night king cuts
across the north to get to Winterfell he
will most likely take out these bigger
targets - I do have a feeling this will
happen but I'm not sure in which
episodes so far the plot leaked doesn't
sound too crazy there are a few minor
things that I don't agree with but most
of it follows what where characters are
going next some of it would be fairly
easy to guess because the characters
have been telling us what their plans
are but overall it's not too bad right
now based on what I have said what are
your thoughts for this episode what
scenes do you think are fake and what
scenes do you think are close enough to
be real put all your opinions or
questions down below in the comment
section I want to thank you all once
again for coming to the channel to check
out today's video and I also want to
thank my patreon supporters you all came
through big time this month and I really
appreciate you for that have a great day
everyone I'll see you soon bye
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]